it was the spring of 2011 and as they
like to say in commencement speeches I
was getting ready to enter the real
world I had recently graduated from
college and moved to Paris to start my
first job my dream was to become a war
correspondent but the real world that I
found took me into a really different
kind of conflict zone at 22 years old I
was diagnosed with leukemia the doctors
told me and my parents point-blank that
I had about a 35% chance of long-term
survival I couldn't wrap my head around
what that prognosis meant but I
understood that the reality and the life
I'd imagined for myself had shattered
overnight I lost my job my apartment my
independence and I became patient number
five six to four over the next four
years of chemo a clinical trial and a
bone marrow transplant the hospital
became my home my bed the place I loved
24/7 since it was unlikely that I'd ever
get better I had to accept my new
reality and I adapted I became fluent in
medical ease made friends with a group
of other young cancer patients built a
vast collection of neon wigs and learned
to use my rolling IV pole as a
skateboard
I even achieved my dream of becoming a
war correspondent although not in the
way I'd expected it started with a blog
reporting from the frontlines my
hospital bed and it morphed into a
column I wrote
for the New York Times called life
interrupted but but above all else my
focus was on surviving and spoiler alert
I did survive yeah thanks to an army of
supportive humans I'm not just still
here I am toward of my cancer so when
you go through a traumatic experience
like this people treat you differently
they start telling you how much of an
inspiration you are they say you're a
warrior they call you a hero
someone who's lived the mythical hero's
journey
who's endured impossible trials and
against the odds lived to tell the tale
returning better and braver for what
you've been through and this definitely
lines up with my experience cancer
totally transformed my life I left the
hospital knowing exactly who I was and
what I wanted to do in the world and now
every day as the Sun rises I drink a big
glass of celery juice and I followed
this up with 90 minutes of yoga then I
write down 50 things I'm grateful for
onto a scroll of paper that I fold into
an origami crane and fence sailing out
my window
are you seriously believing any of this
I don't do any of these things
I hate yoga and I have no idea how to
fold an origami crane the truth is that
for me the hardest part of my cancer
experience began once the cancer was
gone that heroic journey of the survivor
we see in movies and watch play out on
Instagram it's a myth
it isn't just untrue it's dangerous
because it erases the very real
challenges of recovery now don't get me
wrong I'm incredibly grateful to be
alive and I'm painfully aware that this
struggle is a privilege that many don't
get to experience but it's important
that I tell you what this projection of
heroism and expectation of constant
gratitude does to people who are trying
to recover because being cured is not
where the work of healing ends it's
where it begins I'll never forget the
day I was discharged from the hospital
finally done with treatment those four
years of chemo had taken a toll on my
relationship with my longtime boyfriend
and he'd recently moved out and when I
walked into my apartment it was quiet
eerily so the person I wanted to call in
this moment the person who I knew would
understand everything was my friend
Melissa she was a fellow cancer patient
but she had died three weeks earlier as
I stood there in the doorway of my
apartment I wanted to cry but I was too
tired to cry the adrenaline was gone it
felt as if the inner scaffolding that
had held me together since my diagnosis
had suddenly crumbled I had spent the
past 1500 days working tirelessly to
achieve one goal to survive and now that
I'd done so I realized I had absolutely
no idea
how to live on paper of course I was
better I didn't have leukemia the my
blood counts were back to normal and the
disability checks soon stopped coming to
the outside world I clearly didn't
belong in the kingdom of the sick
anymore but in reality I never felt
further from being well all that chemo
had taken a permanent physical toll on
my body
I wondered what kind of job can I hold
when I need to nap for four hours in the
middle of the day when my misfiring
immune system still sends me to the ER
on a regular basis and then there were
the invisible psychological imprints my
onus had left behind the fears of
relapse the unprocessed grief the demons
of PTSD that descended upon me for days
sometimes weeks we talked about reentry
in the context of war and incarceration
but we don't talk about it as much in
the context of other kinds of traumatic
experiences like an illness because no
one had warned me of the challenges of
reentry
I thought something must be wrong with
me I felt ashamed and with great guilt I
kept reminding myself of how lucky I was
to be alive at all when so many people
like my friend Melissa were not but on
most days I woke up feeling so sad and
lost I could barely breathe
sometimes I even fantasized about
getting sick again and let me tell you
there are so many better things to
fantasize about when you're in your 20s
and recently single
but I miss the hospitals ecosystem like
me everyone and there was broken but out
here among the living
I felt like an imposter overwhelmed and
unable to function I also missed the
sense of clarity I'd felt that my
sickest
during your mortality straight in the
eye has a way of simplifying things of
rerouting your focus to what really
matters and when I was sick I vowed that
if I survived it had to be for something
it had to be to live a good life an
adventurous life
a meaningful one but the question once I
was cured became how I was 27 years old
but no job no partner no structure and
this time I didn't have treatment
protocols or discharge instructions to
help guide my way forward but what I did
have was an inbox full of Internet
messages from strangers over the years
people from all over the world had read
my column and they'd responded with
letters comments and emails it was a mix
as is often the case for writers I got a
lot of unsolicited advice about how to
cure my cancer with things like
essential oils I got some questions
about my bra size but mostly mostly I
heard from people who in their own
different way understood what it was
that I was going through I heard from a
teenage girl in Florida who like me was
coming out of chemo and wrote me a
message composed largely of emojis I
heard from a retired art history
professor in Ohio named Howard who'd
spent most of his life struggling with a
mysterious debilitating health condition
that he'd had from the time he was a
young man I heard from an inmate on
death row in Texas by the name of little
GQ short for gangster Quinn he'd never
been sick a day in his life he does a
thousand push-ups to start off each
morning but he related to what I
described in one column as my in cancer
ation and to the experience of being
confined to a tiny fluorescent room I
know that our situations are different
he wrote to me
but the threat of Jess lurks in both of
our shadows and those lonely first weeks
and months of my recovery these
strangers and their awards became life
Lyons dispatches from people of so many
different backgrounds with so many
different experiences all showing me the
same thing you can be held hostage by
the worst thing that's ever happened to
you and allow it to hijack your
remaining days or you can find a way
forward I knew I needed to make some
kind of change I wanted to be in motion
again to figure out how to unstuck
myself and to get back out into the
world
and so I decided to go on a real journey
not the cancer one or the
mythical hero's journey that everyone
thought I should be on but a real pack
your bags kind of journey I put
everything I owned into storage rented
out my apartment borrowed a car and
talked a very dear but somewhat smelly
friend into joining me together my dog
Oscar and I embarked on a 15,000 mile
road trip around the United States along
the way we visited some of those
strangers who'd written to me I needed
their advice also to say to them thank
you
I went to Ohio and stayed with Howard
the retired professor when you've
suffered a loss or a trauma the impulse
can be to guard your heart
but Howard urged me to open myself up to
uncertainty to the possibilities of new
love new loss Howard will never be cured
of illness and as a young man he had no
way of predicting how long he'd lived
but that didn't stop him from getting
married Howard has grandkids now and
takes weekly ballroom
singing lessons with his wife when I
visited them they'd recently celebrated
their 50th anniversary in his letter to
me he'd written meaning is not found in
the material realm it's not in dinner
jazz cocktails or conversation meaning
is what's left when everything else is
stripped away I went to Texas and I
visited little GQ on death row he asked
me what I did to pass all that time I'd
spent in a hospital room when I told him
I got really really good at Scrabble he
said me too and explained how even
though he spent most of his days in
solitary confinement he and his
neighboring prisoners make board games
out of paper and call out their plays
through their meal slots a testament to
the incredible tenacity of the human
spirit and our ability to adapt with
creativity
and my last stop was in Florida to see
that teenage girl who'd sent me all
those emojis her name is unique which is
perfect because she's the most luminous
curious person I've ever met I asked her
what she wants to do next and she said I
want to go to college and travel and eat
weird foods like octopus that I've never
tasted before and come visit you in New
York and go camping but I'm scared of
bugs but I still want to go camping I
was in awe of her that she could be so
optimistic and so full of plans for the
future given everything she'd been
through but as unique showed me it is
far more radical and dangerous to have
hope than to live hemmed in by fear but
the most important thing I learned on
that road trip is that the divide
between the sick and the well it doesn't
exist the border is porous as we live
longer and longer surviving illnesses
and injuries that would have killed
our grandparents even our parents the
vast majority of us will travel back and
forth between these realms spending much
of our lives somewhere between the two
these are the terms of our existence now
I wish I could say that since coming
home from my road trip
I feel fully healed I don't but once I
stopped expecting myself to return to
the person I'd been through diagnosis
once I learned to accept my body and its
limitations I actually did start to feel
better and in the end I think that's the
trick to stop seeing our health as
binary between sick and healthy well an
unwell whole and broken to stop thinking
that there's some beautiful perfect
state of wellness to strive for and to
quit living in a state of constant
dissatisfaction until we reach it every
single one of us will have our life
interrupted whether it's by the ripcord
of a diagnosis or some other kind of
heartbreak or trauma that brings us to
the floor we need to find ways to live
in the in-between place managing
whatever body and mind we currently have
sometimes all it takes is the ingenuity
of a handmade game of Scrabble or
finding that stripped down kind of
meaning and the love of family and a
night on the ballroom dance floor or
that radical dangerous hope that I'm
guessing will someday lead a teenage
girl terrified of bugs to go camping if
you're able to do that then you've taken
the real hero's journey you've achieved
what it means to actually be well which
is to say alive in the messiest richest
most whole sense thank you that's all
I've got
[Applause]
[Music]